this was me every 10 to 20 minutes of
this film
kick ass kick ass
that was kick ass
you really don't need to watch my review
it's pretty obvious how i felt about the
movie kick ass
2 coming right at ya i got a shirt full
of superheroes today
to symbolize kick-ass too none of these
superheroes are in kick-ass too but i'm
wearing this shirt anyway
let's get on to that film kick ass too
this movie's getting some pretty shitty
reviews
it's like in the 20 range tile for uh
rotten tomatoes and i saw this film and
i
i don't know why this film is obviously
supposed to just deliver
on being a fun entertaining violent film
and it does just that it's supposed to
have moments where you go
that was kick ass the theme of today's
review is a film that kicks ass let's
start off with this hit girl played by
chloe grace moretz
ugh she's not 18. [ __ ] i knew she's
barely turning 16
why why would god do this to me
anyway she rocks it they make her the
main character the
main focus of this story she's really
you know the central core
the the emotion of the film and boy does
she deliver she handles this film
very well very strong performance she's
still badass you get to see
more of her female human sides when
she's 18 i really hope we get to see
more female human sides
that might have been a little
inappropriate even for my taste and the
action in this film fantastic but hit
girls kicking ass she's kicking ass when
other people are kicking ass it is
kicking
ass it brought back that flair that that
that fun action yes i'll give it this
it's not as fresh as the original
it's not as fun as the original imagine
like there's low
medium high and very high kick ass was
very high
and this one is just high so no it's not
as spectacular
but it's still a ton of fun when the
action is there it's great when the
comedy's there
it's funny [ __ ] gets intense things get
thrilling it gives you
just enough emotion just overall it's
super entertaining and you know who else
was really entertaining
the [ __ ] this character was
hilarious i love what they did with him
they totally evolved him that's
something i love about this movie
is that it's a sequel like a real sequel
it feels like a continuation
of this story it's a great follow-up
movie they're following the same
characters that were left alive the
characters the cast
makes it feel fresh enough especially
this guy
he's funny he is super bad in this film
you could say he caused a
fright knight he isn't a very good role
model kcis don't get it
those are three movies he's been in and
the guy who refused to promote this film
jim [ __ ] carrie what
why why didn't he promote this film
because of the violence the violence is
so like it's over the top there's no way
you're gonna take it seriously and at
the end of the day the movie is kind of
sending a message in a way that violence
is not okay so i i don't know why this
guy
is going against it he actually does a
good job he's not
hilarious in the film he's kind of funny
but he's still
cool he's another kick ass character
girdles stripes and stars
or stars and stripes whatever the [ __ ]
my name is
gotta have fun hey yo how you doing
and of course how is kick ass himself
this dude he got cut i kind of liked it
better in the first one where he was
more relatable
you know more of an average guy not
someone who made me feel self-conscious
about myself made me feel like i got to
do more ab workouts
and take more fiber so i am [ __ ] all
the time this is clearly what this guy
did
he is way more kick-ass in this one than
the previous one you actually
buy him as a hero in this one damn they
just took all
the characters that we love and they
amplified them they they really show
them
grow they put them in a new type of
situation where they have to
learn about themselves and overcome new
obstacles again and it
makes sense it's a perfect part too to
explore
it seems like everyone's hating on this
movie because it's not as fresh or as
fun as the first one but it doesn't make
it
a bad movie it's still entertaining as
ever
it's still really funny the action's
still really cool you got a great cast
still assembled
chloe grace moretz she's just so badass
in this film she is so layered
they have super villains and superheroes
that was [ __ ] cool to see all these
people unite because this is the legacy
that kick-ass has
sort of you know caused a catalyst for
it's [ __ ] awesome
it's just a bunch of badass after badass
after bad ass
let me correct that kick ass i honestly
really enjoyed the story
i really enjoyed watching what these
characters have to learn about
themselves and what they have to go
through i know i'm talking about a lot
but i wish
hit girl was real i wish she was real
and was 18. not necessarily chloe grace
moretz because for all i know she could
be a real [ __ ] in real life
but this one no that i would date this
chick i would love to have a girlfriend
who can protect my ass
god knows i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] with a big v
let me get straight to the point here
all in all i gotta say kick ass too got
it right
all right guys thanks for checking out
my review for kick ass too why don't you
go ahead scroll that comment box below
and tell me where is a good place i can
take a celebrity
like chloe grace moretz to a dinner
in three years and if you want to go
ahead and follow me on twitter if you
click that button right there
punch ass i don't know and last but not
least if you want to get updated every
time one of my kick-ass reviews is out
i mean like badass reviews i don't mean
like another review of kick ass go ahead
and click on this button by my kick-ass
dick to subscribe
that's right this dick can kick some ass
and it can do some other things to ass
if you know what i mean
one time real bad ass experience
[ __ ] everywhere